ก็สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะน้องอาร์ตี้
สวัสดีครับนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุก
คน
มาเรียนภาษาไทยกันครับ
เอาบ้านผอมก่อนวันที่วันที่ก่อน 5 วันนี้
ใช่ไหมครับวันนี้วันนี้วันนี้วันอะไรคะนิ
ที่วันนี้ก่อนอ้วนนี้วัน
พฤหัสครับว้าววันพฤหัสบดีวันนี้
พฤหัสบดีวันเท่าไหร่วันนี้วันพฤหัสบดีวัน
ที่
25 ครับวันที่ 25 วันพฤหัสบดีที่ 25 ใช่
แล้วเดือนอะไรคะอ๋ออ๋อเดือนนี้ครับเดือน
นี้เดือน
พฤศจิกายนครับเดือน
พฤศจิกายนให้เดือนพฤศจิกายนครับหรือไม่มี
อะไรคะปีนี้ปีพต
วิเคราะห์ศ.สอบสุพรรณ 21 ครับฮ่าๆๆ
ขอศ.
2020 เอ็ดปีนี้ปีพตเท่าไหร่คะ 5 ปีนี้ปี
พต
วาวแสงครับห้าร้อยห้าร้อยสี่ถูกต้องใคร
ครับเวลาครับเวลาด้วยใช่ไหมเวลาเวลากี่
โมงล่ะ
อาร์ม
9:00 น
5 เวลา 21:00 นใช่ครับ 3 ทุ่มกับ 10
นาทีไหมคะ
9:10 นนใช่แล้วหัวหน้าตอนนี้ 10 นาที
อ้าว 9:10 นนตอนนี้เอ่ออ่าเอสตอนนี้ 21:00
นแล้วพี่เอ๋พี่เอ๋กินข้าวกินข้าวหรือยัง
ครับเอาจริงๆใช่ไหมเอาจริงๆยังจริงๆกิน
หรือยัง
ยังไม่ได้กินโห
[เพลง]
มาแล้วไมครู Arty ถามครูเอ๋เอ๋กินข้าว
หรือยังอ๋ออ๋อเพราะว่าขวดอี้ครึ่งกินข้าว
กินข้าวเสร็จแล้วๆกับกินข้าวเสร็จแล้ว
ห้องทำคลิปมาพูดกับครูเองๆๆ
กินอะไรคะขอขวดอีกินผัดกระเพราครับ
ผัดกล้าได้กระเพราอะไรเป็นยังไงกระเพรา
ผัดกระเพรามีครับขวดติถ่ายรูปขัดกระเพรา
มานี่มี
ผัดกะเพราอะไรคะให้ครับอันนี้เป็นผัด
กระเพราหมูสับ
หมู
โหยสติทุกบวกที่จะวาดรูปอ่ะ
โป้นักเรียนนักเรียนช่วยพี่ควรตีวาดรูป
หมูหน่อยโอเคหมูหมูหมูต้องมีจมูกกลมอย่าง
นี้อ่ะแล้วก็มีตาด้วยเอารวยที่มีตัว
ข้อมูลด้วยล่ะเขา
นมกลมเหมือนกันนะโอเคสวัสดีวาดกลมเอาไป
แล้วก็มีหางงอใช่ไหมโอเคอ๋อเสียกูอ่ะก็
ต้องมีขาด้วยสิครับโอเคค่ะอ่ะกูเอ๋อะไร
ว่างพูดว่าอะไรนะครับเมื่อกี้อ้าวัดขา
ก่อนคะหมู
ปีขา
4 ขาเลยใช่ไหมครับอาอีกขาหนึ่งมันอยู่
ด้านโน้นเลยนะซิ
เริ่มอยากกินหมูไหมเห็นหมูกลัวตี้แล้ว
เนี่ยอ้ะหมูอันกระเพราหมูอาจจะไม่อร่อยฮะ
โอเคถ้าหมูสับมันก็ต้องมีเขียนใช่ไหมอ่ะ
อ้าใช้เขียงไงอ่ะใช้แล้ว
มีดครูเอ๋ยังไม่ได้กินข้าวแล้วมีมีดมี
เขียงด้วยกำลังจะทำผัดกระเพราหรือเปล่า
ครับแล้วก็ Amy หมูด้วยค่ะพี่
ว้าวกลัวมี
อ้าวมีแขวนด้วยมีเนื้อหมูค่ะเดี๋ยวกูเอง
ซ้ำเลยนะคะ
ศัพท์ตอนนี้เลยโอ้น่าจะได้ผัดกระเพราเออ
อาจกับเค้าแล้วก็มีรีด
เสียงนะคะค่ะเอาหมูออกมาแล้วก็ได้ครับ
ทราบทราบแบบนี้สักป๊อกๆๆ
ผับบาร์ขอหนังขอ
[เพลง]
นี้หมูตอบด้วยโอเคแล้ว
หัวใจที่ได้ครับเอาไปเก็บก่อนนะพรุ่งนี้
แล้วค่ะอ๋อในถังกะเพราหมูสับก็ต้องมีหมู
แล้วก็มีมีดแล้วก็สับหมูนะจ๊ะชายได้ครับ
สวัสดีคู๋เอามีดเก็บเขียนเก็บก่อนนะฮะถ้า
ได้ครับเขามีเก็บก่อนเอาเขียนเก็บมามีแต่
เก็บ
หานี้ครับในผัดกระเพราวันที่เอามีอะไร
บ้างเอา 5 ในผัดกระเพรามีหมูแล้วก็ต้องมี
มีอะไรอีกครับมีกะเพราสิครับผัดกระเพรา
ต้องมีค่ะผับ kuai มีกะเพราไหมคุยกับตอน
นี้พืชแล้วเก็บไม่ได้แล้วค่ะก็ขอกะเพรา
อยู่นอกบ้านจังนี่ขวดอีมี่รูปกับเหล่า
ๆต่อเท่าสีเขียวใช่ใช่ครับหน้ามีหมูอ๋อ
เอาใช่กะเพราหอม
แล้วมีกะเพราแล้วมีอะไรอีกคะมีกระเพรา
แล้วก็มีกระเทียมด้วยข้อไหนนี่ครับ
กระเทียมกระเทียมผู้เพียงแบบนี้อ้านี่
เหมือนกันเลยเหมือนกันเลยมีมีเปลือก
กระเทียม
ชายกระเทียมมีเปลือกเราต้องแกะเปลือกออก
เราไม่กินเปลือกไม่กินได้ออกแกะเปลือกออก
นะคู๋ใหญ๋ได้กลิ่น
กู ah อายครับกระเทียมมีกลิ่นมิมีกลิ่น
กระเทียมนิถังขยะใส่อ้าเปลือกไม่กินทิ้ง
ไปทิ้งเปลืกข้
คู๋ได้แล้วมีกระเทียมได้กระเทียมแล้วนี่
เนี่ยเป็น
จะสีเหลืองนี่ชิ้นเล็กๆ
[เพลง]
ไหนๆกูเองแก่กระเทียมอยู่ไหนนี่หว่าว้าวๆ
กระเทียม
หอมไหมครับอ้าน่ากลัวตี้กลัวที่ไม่ได้
กลิ่น
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
คิดกระเทียมพอ
หอมกระเทียมหอมมีกลิ่นหอมดูอัดที่
ขับว่ากระเทียมหอม
ครูเอ๋คิดกระเทียมหอม
เรียนคิดอะไรคะน่าคิดขอเพียงม.คหอมไหม
ครับน้า
เหม็นฮ่าๆๆขอผัดกะเพราก็เอานักเรียนต้อง
คอมเม้นข้างล่างนะหน้าครับเทียมของเจของ r
b เหม็นเหม็นอ้ะ a หรือ B ครับเออ
คอมเม้นข้างล่างใช่ครับกระเทียมกวางปาก
เก็บกระเทียมก่อนนะ
หน้านี่ก็กระเทียมแล้วก็เทียมเขาทำยังไง
คะในนั้นอ้ะก็เทียมนี่กูเห็นปอบเสร็จแล้ว
ใช่ไหมปอกกระเทียมเสร็จแล้วก็ต้องเอามา
ตั้งบุฟเฟร์แต่ครูเอ๋มีครบมีครบใช้ครบได้
ครับเช็คครบ
50 ลงไปแล้วก็มี 3 อ่านนั้นสาดก็ได้นะ
ครับตาม
มีกระเทียมต่ำห้าต่ำอ่ะมิมีอะไรต้องตำอีก
ไหมคะอ้ามีออกมีพริกด้วยพริกก็ต่ำนี่
นี่พลีคมีพริกพีคแค่ครับมีพริกผัดกระเพรา
มีพริกด้วยมีกระเพรามีพริกไปครับอ่ามีหมู
สับหน้าเอาพริกใส่ลงไปครับเอาพิษใส่ลงไป
ครับเดี๋ยวเสร็จคลิปนี้ครูเอ๋กินเลยนะคะ
ได้เขากินผัดกะเพราหมูเนื้อหน้าไก่ใส่ลง
ไปใช่ครับ 2  5  pic  2 เมตรเห็ดไหมครู
เอกกินเผ็ดมั้ยครับเอกชอบเผ็ดอ๋อล้อๆชอบ
เผ็ดใส่เยอะก็อ่าสภาพไม่ชอบเผ็ดใส่น้อย
ใส่เยอะๆนะโอ้โหใส่เยอะเลยเกแล้ว
ก็ตามตามใช่ครับตั้มหา
เำพริกก็จะเป็นแบบนี้นี่ขึ้นแบบนี้หอมใช่
หอมนักเรียนไม่ต้องดูนะเดี๋ยวครูเอ๋
กูอะตี้เอทตาม
ตามๆใช้ครับตำพริกพริกอ้ะได้ครับคู่เอกยก
ยกไปเก็บกว่าขาหาได้ครับยกไปเก็บก่อนว้าว
อ้าโอ้โหมาแล้วผู้เอกเก็บแล้วโอเคเก็บลบ
แล้วกำลังหอม Stitch
ตัวเองหอมและหิวด้วยอ่ะถ้าหิวผัดกระเพรา
ไก่เจเวลาครับกินผัดหมี่กะเพราหมูสับใช่
ไหมครับหมู
สับเนี่ย
อาชีพใส่พริกกี่เมตรอ่าใส่พริก 5 เมตร
ครับถ้าเม็ดอะพริกเม็ดใหญ่แหละนี่เม็ด
ใหญ่อ่ะ 5 เมตรใช่ครับเห็น
เผ็ดนิดหน่อยเผ็ดนิดหน่อยเป็นอะไรหน่อย
อ่ะเอกชอบเผ็ดๆโหเผ็ดเยอะใส่พริก 10 เม็ด
ไหมครับ 11 นะ
โอเคหรอกูเอกชอบเผ็ดน้อยค่ะกระเพราไก่นะ
คะเนื้อเพลงเรามีหมูสับกันหนูเยี่ยม
เอาพริกพริกอ้ะไม่มีอะไรครับอ๋ออ๋อผัด
กระเพราก็ต้องมีมีน้ำ
น้ำปลาด้วย
ใช่มีครับน้ำปลา
อร่อยๆหัวดิหนาวหรือปลาน้ำปลาหรือหิว
น้ำปลาเค็มใส่น้ำปลานิดเดียวใส่นิดเดียว
อาศัยเยอะเค็มอาบน้ำน่าได้ครับมีน้ำปลา
แล้วก็มีมีอะไรอีกคะอ้านี่ครับมีน้ำตาลมี
ครับถ้าน้ำตาลหวาน
หน้าใส่น้ำปลาแล้วก็ใส่น้ำตาลด้วยแล้ว
ใส่น้ำแล้วก็ได้ด้วยใส่น้ำตาลเป็นเม็ด
เล็กๆก็ได้นะคะถ้าใช่ครับอันนั้นเรียก
เรียกน้ำตาลทรายสีน้ำตาลทรายครับวันนี้
เอาไปให้ดูคู๋มีน้ำตาลทรายให้นักเรียนดี
ด้วยหรือไม่รับรอจะได้นะคะพร้อมนี่
[เพลง]
มาแล้ว
มาแล้วคุณอาตี้ทำกระเพราใส่น้ำตาลปี๊บใช่
ไหมคะใช่ครับน้ำตาลปี๊บปี๊บ
อะไรคะ
อันนี้น้ำตาลเปิดท่อน้ำตาลทรายครับถ้า
ครับเป็นเปิดเกมใครใช้น้ำตาล
ขอน้ำตาลซ้ายเห็นไหมต่างทรายใช่ไหมเป็น
เมตรเฟซเนี่ยเล็กนะน้ำตาลทรายน้ำตาลทราย
อ่ะ
ใส่น้ำตาลได้น้ำตาลทรายได้ใส่ตาลปึกฮ่าๆๆ
นะคะ
ชอบน้ำตาลอะไรใส่น้ำตานั้นนะคะอ่าหาครับ
ไปอะไรอีกคะทรายอะไรอีก
บางครั้งปวดอีใส่ซีอิ้วดำคู๋ใส่ซีอิ้วดำ
ไหมเวลากูเอกผัดกระเพราใส่ถ้าครูเอ๋ทำคู๋
ไม่ใส่
แต่ถ้าเก๋เดินไปข้างนอกแล้วผัดกระเพรา 1
จานหาใส่ซีอิ้วดำไปซีอิ้วดำนิดนึงนิด
เดียวตายๆครับ
มีต้องใส่น้ำมันด้วยไหมคะอ่ะใส่น้ำมัน
ด้วยครับใส่น้ำมันนิดเดียวมีอะไรครับรูป
น้ำมันไหมคะอ้าขวดดิไม่พี่รูปธรรมมันก็
เออเดี๋ยวกู a ให้ดูรูปน้ำมันมีรูปน้ำมัน
น้ำมันนักเรียนรู้จักไหมรู้จักน้ำมันไหม
ครับ B1 ไม่รู้
น้ำมันนี่เดี๋ยวคุยเอาน้ำมันให้ครัวตีวาด
จะไม่นักเรียนก็จะคิดคิดไม่หอกว่าน้ำมัน
เห็นไหมหน้าไหนครับน้ำมันอ๊อดเห็นแล้ว
กลัวที่เห็นน้ำมันแล้วสีเหลืองเหลืองๆใช่
ไหมเจ๊อ้านี้นี้น้ำมันน้ำมันสักครู่นะคะ
อติ
ขอ
เห็นไม่ชัดใช่ไหมคะนี้ครับมีน้ำมันกวนตีน
น้ำมันด้วยกว่าตีเมื่อกี้ไม่ได้ยินมีอะไร
นะ
ไม่มีอะไรก็พูดได้เลยค่ะมีน้ำมันครับนี้
มีน้ำมันใส่น้ำมันถ้วยไข้ครับพันกับเขา
ต้องมีน้ำมันนะคะแล้วก็เอากระเทียม
ใส่แล้วก็ถ่ายขัดตายครับแล้วก็
อีกแล้วก็ใส่หมูใช่ครับหมูสับใส่แล้วก็
ผัดไปครับ
แล้วก็ใช่น้ำปลาอ้าแล้วก็ใส่น้ำอาร์โอนิด
นึงใส่นะอ้าใช่ครับใส่น้ำตาลให้น้ำตาล
ด้วยครับแล้วก็ซีอิ้วดำซีอิ้วดำนี่ใส่สี
ดำครับ
อร่อย
แล้วก็จะได้เอากระเพราหมูสับ
ยังไม่ได้ใส่กลางเลยออก God ไปใช่ๆใส่กะ
เพราก่อนมีใส่กะเพราก่อนไปกับข้าวแล้วก็
ขัดเอาขึ้น
ใต้ขึ้นมาก็จะได้ผัดกระเพราหมูสับหมี
พูห์อตตี้ชอบกินผัด 5 กะเพราหมูสับราคา
ชอบกินผัดกระเพราหมูสับครับ
[เพลง]
เอกก็ชอบกินภาพกะเพราหมูสับตอนนี้กูเองก็
แหละ
หิว
คลิกอะเวลาต่ำแล้วมัน
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ใช่ครับแล้วถ้าแล้วถ้าอ่อนนักเรียนอาไม่
ชอบหมูสับอ่ะใช่นักเรียนไม่ขึ้นหมูจะทำ
ยังไงอ้าถ้าไม่กินหมูก็เอาก็ใส่ไก่ไอ้ได้
ครับ
ไก่ก็ได้อ้าเราก็ไม่ใส่หมูไก่ๆก็พูดว่า
อะไรคะพูดว่ากระเพราไอ้ห่าๆครับเราไก่ใช่
ไหม
กระเพราไก่นะคะ
หมูไม่กินหายินไก่ก็ไม่กิน
ไก่ก็ไม่กินไม่ชอบกินไม่ชอบใช่ไหมอ่ะถ้า
งั้นใส่ได้ครับนี่กระเพรากุ้งอาร์ไม่ใส่
หมูไม่ใส่ไก่ใส่กุ้งน่ากินว่าอ่ะร้าน
อาหารแจ้งเขาเองค่ะและอิ่มกุ้งน่ะกูเอง
กินมาอกหรอคันแต่กูเองชอบนะ
ภาพกุ้งคันไม่กินกุ้งใช่ไหมค่ะ
ไม่กินกุ้ง
ใส่อะไรได้อีกก็ใส่ไซส์อะไรอ่ะหมึกๆครับ
ปลาหมึก
ตัวเองกำลังจะตายคิว
หิวเราเปิดกระเป๋ามือ
กูไอ้ตี้ของแอนตี้นะคะ
คอสไอกระเพราเต้าหู้ได้ครับเธอมาไอ้ใส่
หมูหมูไม่ใส่ถ่ายให้ใส่ปลาหมึกไม่ใส่กุ้ง
ใส่เต้าหู้อ่ะกูเอกำลัง
มีอะไรล่ะหาหา
รูปคู่ใช่ไหมเอ๋มีนะดีมั้ยมีมั้ยเอา
เลขพร้อมเอาๆกูได้ครับถ้านักเรียนตอบนี่
อ๋ออ๋อทรายใส่สี
เห็นหน้าเห็นเห็นกระเพรางูอ้าให้ดูใกล้ๆ
เต้าหู้
หาๆก็หายไปแล้วเอากูอ่ะเขากระเพราเอาคู่
แย่นี่ไงใช้ครับข้าว
[เพลง]
อย่างนะ
สักครู่นะคะกวาดหน้าได้ใครคอขวดเดียวรอ
นี่ค่ะครับ
พี่ปุ้ยเฮ้ย
เห็นลืมนี่กระเพราเต้าหู้
ว้าวน่ากินเบื่อเหมือนกันชายใช่
กูเปล่าหมูสับค่ะเอาไอข่าวคู่
ว้าวเขาประเมินอีก
ที่ครับครูอาชีพมีครู Arty มีรูปก็เพรา
หมูสับใช่ไหมคะใช่ครับ
สาบเอาหมูสาบ
กระเพราไก่กระเพราไก่นี่กระเป๋าไปอาบ
กระเพรากุ้งอ้านี่ครับกระเพรากุ้งข้าว
แล้วก็กลับเคราปลาหมึก
กระเพราหมึก OA เมย์เอากระเพราเต้าหู้
เต้าหู้ใช่ครับตัวอติชอบกินผัดกระเพรา
อะไรมากที่สุดคะก็วันที่ชอบมากที่สุดก็
คือผัดกระเพรา
ปุ้งเขา
verti กินกุ้งได้ไม่คันไม่ขาดครูเอ๋
[เพลง]
ครูเอ๋ชอบกระเพรา
มาก
แต่เมื่อก่อนกินกุ้งโอเค
แต่ตอนนี้กินกุ้งแล้วคัน
ก็ดูแล้วก็ไม่
เป็นเขาปลาหมึกแทนนะดีแล้วครูแห่นะครับ
เอกข้อกระเพราอะไร
มากที่สุดครับตอนนี้ใช่ไหมคะกุ้งใบได้หาย
ตัวไป by
ครูเอ๋ชอบปลาหมึกชอบแต่ว่ามหาย kuai ชอบ
กระเพราหมูสับขอชอบเค้าหมูสับมากที่สุด
หน้ามากที่สุดนะ
นะเรียนนะคะ
นักเรียนค่ะครูเอ๋มีคำถามหนึ่งนักเรียน
กินผัดกระเพรามั้ยอ๋อเจ้เอกิน
ลีไม่กิน
มหาบีไม่เอาไม่เอาผัดกระเพรา
We  Are
ราคาครูเอ๋อยากรู้นักเรียนกินผัดกระเพรา
ไหม
ครับถ้ารักเรียนกินผัดกระเพราเออ
นักเรียนกินผัดกระเพราอะไรใช่มั้ยอ๋อคะ
กินอัดกระเพรากินผัดกระเพราใครนะได้ครับ
ครูอาจตี้น่ะกินกินผัดกระเพราหมูอ่ากิน
ผัดกับกระเพราไก่กินไหมคะอ่ะกินข้าวกระ
เพรากุ้งอ้ายกะเพรากู้เกาะกินกระเพราปลา
หมึก
เอาปลาหมึกก็กินข้าวเข้าตู้
in ข้าว
นักเรียนกินผัดกระเพราอะไรใช่ไหมคะใจถ้า
อยากรู้อยากรู้แต่กู Arty อ่ะทีมาใน
คอมเม้นต์ 5k ได้ถ้าเขา
หิวแล้วอ่ะฮ่าๆกูเองมากมีพริกละ
มาถ้าหิวแล้วเดี๋ยวๆอา-ราเราให้ครูเอ๋เอ๋
ไออัดกระเพราตอนนี้ถามฮัดชิ่วแล้วพริก
กลิ่นมิกซ์ริน
กลิ่นกระเทียม
เป็นพริกน่ะเวลาผัดมาจะดีกลิ่นใช่ไหมมี
อาหิวแล้วก็เวลาหมดเวลาก็หมดแล้วใช่ครับๆ
เดี๋ยวครับคู๋ก็จะไปทำผัดกระเพรา
อ้าวเก๊า
ติดต่อจะทำผัดกระเพราหมูใช่ไหมค่ะอ่า
เอ่อโอเคขาวันนี้นักเรียนก็รู้จักอาหาร
ไทยผัดตายเพราราคา
อร่อย
ไปครับอร่อยนะคะฮ่าๆๆโอเคเนาะอ่าก่อนดึก
แล้วครู Arty ต้องไปอาบน้ำใช่มั้ยอ้ะได้
ครับอ่ะกูเอกก็ไปผัดกระเพราเขียวคราวหน้า
เราหน้าเรากลับมาเรียนภาษาไทยกับอ่ะคู๋
กับควรตีในช่องคอมเปลี่ยนสวาไทย
ผมหน้าวันนี้หน้าบ๊ายบายครับอาสวัสดีครับ
ครูเอ๋สวัสดีครับ
บ๊ายบายค่ะ
ม.ค